FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
69 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc Campoy.
And I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I am very good.
I feel relaxed after
Cloud Next is over--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --yeah, we
don't have anything to do,
right?
MARK MANDEL: I just nap now.
That's just what I do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And Google IO.
You know, nothing.
We cool, we cool now.
And we have today a
very cool interview
with one of our customers.
So we're going to have David
Mytton from Server Density.
We'll see exactly what they do.
They do not do dense servers.
There was a joke there.
They basically build like a
monitoring logging solution.
And it's open source.
It runs on Google
Cloud Platform.
And they had a very
interesting story
of migrating from on-premise
MongoDB to Bigtable.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
And then after that, we will
have our question of the week,
where are we looking at latency
times across the GCP network.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Where
should I run my machine
so my customers in this
area are the happiest?
We'll answer that question.
But before that, we have,
as usual, our cool things
of the week.
And I'm going to
start with the one
that I brought because
I think it's super cool.
MARK MANDEL: Go on, then.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: This
weekend I watched
a bunch of Cloud Next docs.
I always said I was
binge watching Next.
And one of the talks,
actually two of the talks
that really blew my mind
were from Martin Gorner
from our team.
He gave two talks on
TensorFlow, they're
called "TensorFlow and Deep
Learning without a PhD."
And it turned out very well
because I do not have a PhD.
And he basically goes from what
are the basics of TensorFlow
to training a neural network
with all the works of William
Shakespeare, and generating
new William Shakespeare fan
fiction, you could say.
William Shakespeare fan fiction
with [? Daniel ?] network--
and the result is amazing.
He also uses the same technique
to generate Python code.
So he trains the
TensorFlow neural network
with the TensorFlow
source code, and then he
generates new TensorFlow code.
MARK MANDEL: It looks like
it would work in theory.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah!
MARK MANDEL: Like, close.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: To the point
that it starts with the Apache
v2 license on top of the file.
It is actually really amazing.
It generates code that looks
like I could have written it,
really.
Also, I don't write
that good Python.
I guess that's why.
MARK MANDEL: We
probably can't judge.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But go check it out.
It's like two hours of
content, but it's definitely
worth your time if you
are curious about what
you can do with deep
learning, and you
want to learn from scratch
and without getting
too much detail into the
mathematics concept behind it--
you just want to
know how to do it.
MARK MANDEL: Cool!
My cool thing is the
announcement of the Data Loss
Prevention API.
I actually think
it's really cool.
When I first actually saw
this, I just saw the video
and I was like, oh,
that's really neat.
And then I realized it was
our product, in which case
I was actually really excited.
So the cool thing about
this is it's, again,
a predefined machine
learning tool.
But what it does is it
will remove and classify
sensitive information, so social
security numbers, credit card
numbers, phone numbers,
all sorts of other types
of sensitive data.
And you don't really have to do
a huge amount of work for it.
So you can just
send it at the API
and then it will send it
back going, oh, hey, let's
just redact all these things
from it, which is pretty sweet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I discovered this thing during
one of the Cloud Next keynotes.
It was really cool
because they show,
imagine that you're in a chat
and you're talking to someone
and you're like, hey, I will
need your, I don't know,
your account number.
And they're like, yeah,
this is my account number,
this is my social security
number, this is my address,
and this is how to
find my children.
You know, it's like,
maybe not give me that,
but now it's already in the
chat so you're storing it.
And with this API,
basically you're
able to find all the
things that are sensitive
and filter them out.
So you can now give access
only to the people that should
be having access to these.
The amazing thing is that
also works on images.
I don't know if you saw that.
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
I didn't see that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
they have an example where
they put a picture,
and the picture
is a picture of a credit card.
And on the credit
card, it removes only
the credit card number, but
not the name of the person.
Because the name of the person
is not considered as sensitive,
but the credit card number is.
So it is really cool.
MARK MANDEL: It is
really, really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it's pretty amazing.
I guess that that's
one of the things
that you can do when you
have amazing deep learning
with TensorFlow.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Looking
back to the one before.
And we have one more
cool thing of the week.
And I'm going to say
that, is this really cool?
No, just kidding.
MARK MANDEL: Whoa.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Just kidding.
MARK MANDEL: You know how
to make friends, don't you?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Just
kidding, just kidding.
I think it is very cool
and it is pretty exciting
that we have PHP 7.1
on Google App Engine.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Yes, so if PHP is
your thing and you're
looking to use the
latest version of PHP
in your App Engine
apps, you can now
deploy PHP 7.1 on
App Engine Flex.
It's got built-in
containers and built-in
tooling there, so you
can just get that up
and running really, really fast,
as well as using pretty much
all of your favorite frameworks
from Laravel, Symfony,
WordPress, and more.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
fair warning, I guess.
This is App Engine
Flexible Environment,
which it is pretty cool.
And it is now not beta.
It's general availability
since Cloud Next.
We announced that.
So go have a look.
And if you're not into PHP,
there's some people like that.
There's many other
languages that you
can run on App Engine Flex.
So go check it out.
Like, if you're running
Node.js or Ruby or whatever,
we have easy ways to run that
code also on Google App Engine
Flexible Environment.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
And now a quick shout
out, one of the people
who sits next to us in
the office, Brent Shaffer.
He wrote the blog post.
Hi, Brent.
It is a really,
really nice blog post
and there's also a really
great video in there
about deploying PHP
applications on App Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: He says
he listens to the podcast.
Let's see if he actually does.
MARK MANDEL: Find out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great,
so I guess it's time
to go talk to David Mytton
from Server Density.
MARK MANDEL: Let's go do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
very, very excited today
to welcome our guest David
Mytton, CEO and co-founder
of Server Density.
How are you doing, David?
DAVID MYTTON: I'm good.
How are you?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Doing
great, very excited
about all the things
that you have to tell us.
I always love
architecture talks,
and I think that you have a
lot to tell us about that.
But before we get
into all the details,
why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself
and what do you do
at Server Density.
DAVID MYTTON: Yeah, sure.
I'm the co-founder and
CEO at Server Density.
We are a software-as-a-service
based scalable infrastructure
monitoring company.
We help our customers
save time and money
by providing advanced server
and website monitoring, sites
alerting, waking people
up in the middle of night
when stuff's going wrong,
fancy graphs and integrations
across all the cloud providers.
And we've got some
customers like the NHS,
with the emergency
response service
and ambulances here in the
UK, and also Drupal, Firebox,
and [? especially ?]
the graphing is all
we're going to be
talking about in a bit.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And what do you do
at Server Density?
DAVID MYTTON: I started
the company back in 2009.
So at that point I
was doing everything.
I am along with
my co-founder who
I was working on the
design and the interface,
and we put a lot
of time and effort
into that, building and
graphing the interface.
But I built the original
version of the product,
including our original
time series database.
And over the years
I've hired engineers
who are actually qualified and
have rewritten most of the code
that I wrote in the old days.
So now I'm responsible for
the overall company vision,
how we execute on things.
I am working on the commercial
side as well as dipping in here
and now in the engineering.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So could you tell
us a little bit
about what is
Server Density like?
How it is to use it?
Do you have an API
and people just call
for every single log line?
Do you open a TCP connection?
How is the developer
experience with Server Density?
DAVID MYTTON: There's two
different parts to the product.
The first one, and the original
use case, is server monitoring,
and then that's complemented
by availability monitoring.
And with the server
monitoring side of things,
there's an open source agent.
So I wrote the original
version of that.
And it's packaged up, and you
install it onto your servers.
It runs, executes, commands to
polling the system statistics,
and ties in with
all the applications
you might be running
on the server,
so databases, web servers,
that kind of thing.
It then creates a
payload in JSON,
sends the data back
to our server HTTPS.
And that comes into the
Server Density Platform.
From there, it runs
through an alerting engine.
And that's where we will decide
if the alerts that you've
configured as a
customer are going
to be triggered, whether
we're going to email you, SMS
you, send messages to Slack or
HipChat or anything like that.
And then it routes it to the
time series storage engine
so that we can store that
data for historical reporting,
building graphs, and
showing up dashboards.
And then the second part is
the availability monitoring.
And we have locations
around the world.
That's where we will poll you
APIs and public applications,
endpoints.
Anything that's
available online,
we're looking at
the availability
and the performance.
And then everything
is accessible
through our mobile
apps, our web interface,
and also through our API.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So one of the things
that surprised me out
of the whole thing
that you said was
to log stuff, your open
source agent, what it does
is it sends JSON
payload over HTTP.
And I'm wondering, why is that?
Why not something like gRPC.
Other than the fact
that, of course,
when you created the agent,
gRPC was not a thing.
But like any other option,
binaries or whatever.
DAVID MYTTON: There
were two main reasons.
The first one is that HTTP is
a very well known protocol.
And outbound HTTPS, because
we encrypt the payload,
is typically available
on most environments.
Or if it's not directly
available, then
often there's a proxy.
And avoiding a
custom protocol means
that it's very easy to convince
people to open firewall rules
if they need to for
outbound connectivity.
And the second reason
is, in the early days,
I didn't really know
much about scaling,
I had scaling services,
scaling web services,
but I didn't know about
how to set up load balances
and to scale web.
And I thought that
it would be easier
to scale something just
by using load balances
and Apache at the time, now
NGINX, and then inventing
a custom protocol.
MARK MANDEL: So you talked
a little bit about before,
you said you set up the
original implementation
of how Server Density works.
Can you talk us a
little bit through that?
I believe you weren't
running on Google Cloud,
you were doing some
other different things?
DAVID MYTTON: Yes, that's right.
So there's a couple
of different steps.
And we have migrated a large
portion of the application
over to Google Cloud,
but there's still
a few bits in our
older infrastructure
that's gradually being moved
over over the next few months.
But all I can talk about
is the how it was before,
and then we can go
into all the cool stuff
on Google Cloud
about how it is now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
DAVID MYTTON: So when
the payload comes in,
what came in through
our system, it
goes into the intake
part of the application.
So this is just an
endpoint, an HTTPS endpoint.
And the data comes
in, and that is then
passed through our
load balancers, which
were Apache in
the original days,
and are now running off NGINX.
And that is inserted into
a queuing system, which
we built on top of MongoDB.
The data is stored there,
and then very quickly
is pulled out by
the rules engine.
The original version
of that was in PHP.
That was the first
language that I learnt.
And it has a bad
reputation, but is
incredibly versatile in
being able to do stuff really
quickly.
So the rules engine
looks at the payload.
It does a quick check to
make sure it's valid JSON.
The account exists.
The account is fully
paid up and is active.
And then it will pass
through all the data
and compare it to the
alerts that are configured.
And we do a number
of different checks
to see if an alert
is already open.
If it is already open,
then we might not
want to send another
notification immediately.
And there are
different rules that
allow us to send notifications
at different times.
Once the letter is
being opened, we're
waiting for a certain period
of time for an alert condition
to exist for a couple of minutes
before we send notifications.
But it's all based on
customer configuration.
If we decide to
send a notification,
then there's a
separate queue, again,
in some MongoDB-based queue,
and our notification service,
which has been
rewritten into Python,
and that was the second
language that I learnt.
And that is what sends
emails, sends SMSes,
ties into push
notification gateways,
and sends that out
to the customer.
And then there's a
second route, which
goes into MongoDB for the
time series storage as well.
So that's for the graphing
and the recording.
So there are these two
channels, one for alerting,
and one goes through the rules
engine and then we discard it.
And then there's
a second channel
where it goes into the
time series format,
is transformed into an
optimized storage format,
and then goes into MongoDB.
MARK MANDEL: So this was
the previous implementation
that was running all
these MongoDB instances.
Is that right?
DAVID MYTTON: Yes, that's right.
And that was running on bare
metal servers at SoftLayer.
And we had hundreds of gigabytes
of RAM, many terabytes of SSDs.
And it was several years
worth of iterations on that
that I did in the very
beginning to give us really,
really fast loading graphs
for what is the most commonly
accessed time view,
which is usually
the last couple of hours
up to the last 24 hours
for customers, and that
is slightly less optimized
in terms of the graph
loading time for time periods
going beyond that.
MARK MANDEL: I'm curious now.
So you're running like your own
sort of sharded MongoDB replica
sets?
How are you managing that?
Was that all just
a manual process?
How was that managed?
DAVID MYTTON: Yeah, it was
the MongoDB replica sets
way of sharding.
So that was a single database
and a single collection
in MongoDB, and we split it out
into different granularities.
So the agent reports
back every minute
and we store that data
every minute for a week.
And then it's also,
at the same time,
written into a
different database
to give hourly averages.
And that data is stored forever.
And due to the
architecture of MongoDB
at the time, the database
level lock that they had,
which has now been improved
significantly in the latest
storage engines, we split them
out into different databases
and sharded them separately.
But aside from that being
kind of a limitation of Mongo,
it also allowed us the benefit
of being able to split them out
into different clusters
based on the use case,
because hourly data is accessed
less often, so we could have
cheaper hardware to
power that cluster.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you were mentioning that
that is previous architecture.
So what about the new one?
What were the
issues, or what were
the advantages on the
new architecture that
made you move?
DAVID MYTTON: There were
a couple of challenges.
And we reached these,
I think, about a year
ago to the beginning
of last year.
And we got to the point
where the current system
was no longer scaling.
In particular, we had
to spend a lot of time
maintaining that infrastructure.
So we didn't own the
servers, but they
were bare metal servers.
And we were renting
them from SoftLayer.
And every so often we'd have
disk failures or hardware
failures and we'd have to
deal with upgrading them.
So there was just a lot of
time consuming maintenance
that our team had to do.
We also wanted to build
a lot more features.
And because we'd completely
custom-designed essentially
the database schema to fit
this, and the APIs, all
the functionality, and the
whole architecture around it,
it was a completely
custom system.
And we're a small team, we're
20 people, which two of them
are engineers, but we have so
many feature requests coming in
that we didn't have enough
time to dedicate to building.
I was spending a lot of time
building time series, data
functionality, so things
like doing math functions
and being able to pull out data
from different granularities
and combine it.
All the applications,
all of these standard
features that you'd
expect to be able to see,
we didn't have
time to build them.
Also, the scaling
was a challenge.
So the replication and scaling
in MongoDB is pretty good.
But you can't do it
in a linear fashion.
You have to set up an entirely
new cluster for a new shard.
And then data has to
move around, to migrate.
You've got to make sure
that there's enough
overhead to move that data.
So adding new clusters
in was an overhead.
And then, finally,
it's very expensive
to buy all that memory
and all those SSDs.
And it was a fun thing
to say that we've
got terabytes of SSDs,
but when you're actually
looking at the overall cost,
it was really expensive.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So what does the new
architecture look like?
I think you're on GCP now.
What are you using?
What's connected to what?
DAVID MYTTON:
Yeah, that's right.
So the time series
database that was MongoDB
is now Cloud Bigtable.
And that is running
mostly on Google Cloud.
But the intake aspect of
it is still in SoftLayer.
It's just in a new architecture.
And it was about 18
months ago, two years ago,
that we rewrote that bit.
And unfortunately the Pub/Sub
product wasn't fully available.
So we ended up having
to build it ourselves
on top of Kafka install.
So to go back to how
the data comes in--
it's coming in from the agent,
it goes into that intake part
again.
So instead of it going
into a MongoDB queue,
it now goes into Kafka.
So Kafka is the Apache open
source project queuing system.
That's then pulled out using
Storm, which is a big data
event-based processing system.
It basically gives
us a framework
to process all that data.
The rules engine was rewritten
from PHP into Python.
That's the language
that we've standardized
across the whole company.
And new things are
written in Python now.
So all the rules
engine, which replicated
in Python and with a modern
test suite and integration test
and everything that you'd
expect from a properly planned
and written project, rather
than something that I wrote
and then scaled over the years.
And then the notification
system, again, that first route
is still the same--
with some improvements,
but that's in Python still.
And then the second route
is the entirely new bit
on top of Google Cloud Platform.
So part of this was
also-- it's also
the first bit of our migration
over to Google Cloud.
So we had the challenge of
running the primary structure
in SoftLayer, but having the
time series database running
on Google Cloud Platform.
And what we have to do
is-- because the system
is built in a
microservices architecture,
then we have all
these APIs internally.
So it is relatively
straightforward
to extract this entire
component, move over to Google,
and have it continue to
communicate over HTTPS, even
across the internet,
which is what we did.
So that second route now looks
like just an internal API
as opposed to HTTPS.
And that goes into
the Google load
balances that gives us
the high availability
and the scalability.
The internal API is
written in Python again.
And it's just exposing
the functionality.
It's a very light wrapper
on top of OpenTSDB,
which is the time series
database product that we use.
This is open source,
and has allowed
us to solve that problem
of not having enough time
to build all the features that
we want into the time series
database because it has
so many different features
available out of the box.
So we're now starting to
build into the product.
And we've been able to
contribute a few fixes back as
well, because it's an
open source project.
And then the final part
of it is that OpenTSDB
is talking to Cloud Bigtable.
And that's where the actual
storage of the data sits.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Tell us a little bit
about how OpenTSDB works
and how that whole
thing goes together,
I'm quite curious about it.
DAVID MYTTON: Yes.
The OpenTSDB instance
is entirely stateless,
so we're running backs on
Google Container Engine,
so it's all shiny new
containers running
on Kubernetes, which
was a lot of fun
too for our team to
play around with.
But essentially, it gives you
an optimized storage format,
which has a driver too, and
store that into Cloud BigTable.
And it then gives you an API
to be able to query the data,
and has various functions so you
can aggregate and perform math
functions on top of the data--
so queried based on tags.
So this gives us
all those features
that we wanted in terms
of being able to offer
the graphing to our customers.
MARK MANDEL: And how
is the experience
being in terms of being
able to scale BigTable?
How's that worked for you?
DAVID MYTTON: So
the best part of it
probably is that it's a
completely managed service,
and this was one of the biggest
reasons for us moving over.
So when I wrote the original
version of our MongoDB system,
I chose MongoDB because there
was nothing else available.
BigTable didn't exist as a
publicly available product,
and databases like
Cassandra, which
have a good reputation
for time series data,
didn't exist the first time
I came to work with MongoDB.
So it gave us a
really good product
that scaled over the years
to have really, really fast
writes.
And I'm surprised at how
well it scaled over, well,
seven years, really, of
the company existing.
But it required a huge
amount of my time.
And then, when we hired people,
this required a lot of time
internally to continue
to maintain it.
So just being able to have
a database product that's
managed by Google, all the
failover, the redundancy,
the design, everything
is just handled by Google
so that we don't have to
deal with any of that.
And it's not a general
purpose database.
It's very specifically
designed for time series data
and that means we get
incredible performance from it,
and that allows us
to reduce the costs
just because we don't need
all that expensive hardware.
And then, specifically in
terms of the scalability,
it is essentially linear.
We know that we can get 10,000
writes per second per node.
And we just press a button,
and in a couple of minutes
we have a new node.
And within about
20 to 30 minutes
the data has rebalanced
across the entire cluster,
and we've added an
extra 10,000 writes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Could you
share a little bit of the amount
of traffic that you're doing?
Or what's the difference in
cost between running your own
servers-- you were saying that
you were owning so many SSDs--
to just migrating everything
to Cloud BigTable?
DAVID MYTTON: The
cost of Cloud BigTable
is a lot more
predictable because we
can see exactly how
many writes per second
we're buying for
the per node cost.
And the graphing the Google
Cloud Platform Control Panel
provides is pretty
good and that just
shows us the absolute numbers.
That means we can
see pretty easily
the exact number of
writes that we're doing
and how we need to scale it.
When it came down to MongoDB
in the previous architecture,
it was not as
transparent in terms
of being able to see where we're
at in terms of the scalability.
There's no direct correlation
between the number of writes
and the hardware that we have.
So we had to do a lot of
benchmarking and testing.
And typically we
would see that we
needed to scale
through proxy metrics,
like the response
times of the APIs,
rather than actually
knowing that we're
hitting the limits of the writes
that the product can provide.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I'm actually curious--
you talked about seemingly
all the good stuff.
Were there any interesting
challenges or issues
that you ran into moving
over to GCP and BigTable
and the new architecture?
DAVID MYTTON: Yes.
There were two
interesting situations
that we were talking about.
So the first time that we
started the test workload
onto BigTable, we did
some tests in MongoDB
and looked at the
number of metrics
that we were writing per
second, and then simulated
some test traffic into BigTable
to see if that actually--
the theory actually played out.
And we saw that we were
doing hundreds of thousands
of writes per second more
than we actually predicted.
And that completely blew
away our cost calculations
because you get 10,000
writes per second per node,
and you just pay
per node, and it
looked like we were going
to go into 200 or 300 nodes
on Bigtable, which would
have been cool to say,
and was fun discussing
with your engineers.
But then we discovered
that OpenTSDB shipped
with an outdated driver.
And it was released before
you released a new batch API.
So your engineer
suggested that we
upgrade to a test version
of the driver, which we did.
And in our test
workload, which was
doing 100,000 writes
per second, as soon
as we switched over
to the new driver,
it went down to 3,000
writes per second--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, wow.
DAVID MYTTON: --which is a
pretty significant difference.
It was a big relief that
our actual calculations
were correct and our original
cost projections were correct.
Then the second lesson
that we learned from that
was to do with the keys,
and this is really important
when you're querying the data.
So the original key was
based on an account ID,
say every account
within server density
gets a unique ID, and
then also the metric name.
And the more items that we
have in an account, the more
data that had to be queried.
And by item I mean
like, a server.
So if we were looking
for load average,
for example, then
the original key
was to look at the account ID
and then look at load average.
But that would query
across every single server
within the account.
So in our performance
testing, that quickly
revealed that we'd made a
mistake with the key query
design, and we needed
to be much more
granular, because for our very
small accounts, it was fine.
But for our accounts with
thousands and thousands
of servers, the
response time was just
completely unacceptable.
So we played around with
a few different options.
And the obvious one
was just to drop
in the item ID in the middle.
So instead of it just
being account ID and then
a metric name, it became
account ID, item ID,
and then the metric name.
And that reduced query
times from 30 to 40 seconds
in some cases, down to less
than a second in most cases,
which is much more
acceptable when you're just
loading a dashboard.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, nice.
Yeah, I guess that
is one of the things
that I've heard many
times about BigTable.
BigTable is, after
all, a key value store.
A very fancy one at it, but
basically a key value store.
So I guess that
choosing the keys
is a very, very
important part of it.
Is there any other aspects
of any best practices
that you may share?
Something that you
learned, say, hey,
this is how you
should be doing keys,
other than what
you just mentioned?
DAVID MYTTON: I think the key
to designing the key set up
is to actually test it.
And we tested with small
data sets to begin with.
It was only when we then started
testing with the production
simulation that we discovered
this performance problem, which
in hindsight is pretty
obvious and is something
that could easily be picked up.
But it was just a simple
mistake in not having
a diverse enough testing set.
And that, I suppose, is
also similar to the problem
we had with the driver.
Once you start putting
production workload through it,
that's when it really
shows up the problems.
Otherwise, you would just
assume just a couple of thousand
writes per second as a test
workload is a reasonably
sized workload for many people.
But as soon as you start pushing
actual production data through,
that's when these little
things will show up.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, we're slowly
running out of time here.
Is there anything we haven't
asked you or anything
you want to mention or
plug or anything like that
before we finish up?
DAVID MYTTON: I think the only
thing would be the HumanOps
community that I started, and
I'm now running, in the US
and also in Europe, which has
come out of my experiences
in the early days
of Server Density
being on call 24 hours a
day for a couple of years,
but now more recently
talking to our customers.
And it's a community
and a series
of meet-ups where we get
companies and individuals
to come along and
talk about how they
are running the human
side of their operations.
We tend to focus on all the
cool shiny tools and systems
that we have in place, but
don't pay enough attention
to the humans that are running
the systems in the sense
of fatigue, getting
too many alerts,
all the stress of being on call,
and how different companies
deal with that.
So we've run an event
in San Francisco.
We're doing one in
April in New York.
And we're also
running one in London.
So just have a look
on HumanOps.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
And since we are
talking about events,
it seems like we'll
see you at Cloud Next.
DAVID MYTTON: Yes, that's right.
On 8th of March, I'm going to
be speaking about this, about
the migration.
I've got some cool
architecture diagrams
so you can visualize what I've
just been talking through.
And we'll see.
I've also got the
graph of that change
to the driver with
that massive drop
from 100,000 down to
3,000 writes per second.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Great.
Well, thank you so much for
joining us today, David.
That was a super
interesting conversation.
DAVID MYTTON: Excellent.
Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So thanks
again to David for such
an interesting interview.
It was pretty enlightening to
be able to see how someone could
go from such a huge traffic
running on MongoDB on-premise
to migrating all of that--
basically, I think
the metaphor is
changing the engine on
a car while it's moving,
or something like that.
MARK MANDEL: I think
people generally say train.
But yeah, that works.
It doesn't matter.
It still works as a metaphor.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'd
say on the train is
easier because you can just--
but whatever.
That's not the important thing.
It was a very interesting thing.
And if you're interested
in knowing more about this,
this interview was
recorded right before Next.
But during Next, they
had a very cool session
called "BigTable in Action,
powering billion user services
and meeting customer's
challenges."
And it is available online, so
you can go check it out now.
And you'll see Sami
Zuhuruddin from Google Cloud,
he's a Senior Solutions
Architect, and also
David Mytton, our friend
we just interviewed,
which is the CEO of Server
Density, and finally,
Anthony Fox, which is the
author of data science at CCRi.
So go check it out.
There's a lot of good lessons
to be learned in there.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, and I always
love really interesting stories
from people who have moved
from one place to another
and why they did that.
Super, super interesting stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it's definitely war stories
that there's failures in
there and lessons in there
that you could learn
so you can avoid them.
So go check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, why don't we move on
to our question of the week.
Today's question of
the week, we want
to talk about
[? queuing ?] times.
So you're building your
next amazing application
and you say to
yourself, which regions
should I put this in for
Google Cloud Platform?
Which ones are going to
give me the lowest latency?
So is there an easy way
to be able to find out
what my latencies could be?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not
only there's an easy way,
but it has an amazing name.
It is GCPing.
So like GCP, but with
I-N-G at the end, which
also is ping, so GCPing.com.
And it is a very simple service.
It is created by someone working
at Google, Jason [? Hull. ?]
He just made this available,
it's a very simple service.
It has one f1-micro instance
running every single one
of our regions, and basically
just shows you the average ping
time from your laptop--
or whatever you're
using, maybe your phone--
to all of those instances.
And it's pretty cool.
For instance, right
now, for me, I
can see that from San Francisco,
the shortest ping is US west
1, which is not surprising.
But I was actually surprised
that Europe west 1 is slightly
longer than Asia east
1, which kind of makes
sense because Asia east
is just the ocean, so we
have a cable going through.
But US west 1, you need to
go through the United States
and then through the ocean.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
There's like mountains
and stuff in the way.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so
it kind of makes sense.
That if you didn't think
about it, even flying,
actually, I'd say that Paris
is shorter than Hong Kong.
Apparently that doesn't count.
MARK MANDEL: It doesn't count.
We have cables.
But one thing I
really like about this
is there's a global
world in there.
So what he does is he
set up a global HTTP load
balancer, which will then route
the request to the nearest
healthy instance.
So what's neat about that is you
can actually see that for me,
again, same as San
Francisco, US west 1,
I get about 28 milliseconds.
And your mileage may
vary for obvious reasons.
But then my global
is 31 milliseconds.
So there's a small difference
as it goes through the load
balance every few milliseconds,
but you can pretty much
determine where it's
actually routed you
to the correct place
that is closest to you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it is very cool
because you can imagine that
if you want your instance
to be accessible
from-- your application
to be accessible and fast
everywhere in the world, yeah,
you need to have a global
HTTP load balancer.
That is the answer, basically.
But if you are depending
on a specific region,
yeah, GCPing.com and you can see
which one is the closest one.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, Francesc,
where are you off to?
What are you up to?
What are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm going to
be recording one more episode.
Actually, I just released
an episode of JustForFunc.
For those that do not
know what JustForFunc is,
it's this YouTube
series that I've been
creating for quite a while now.
And I just finished
with Flappy Gopher,
so now we have a clone of
Flappy Bird [INAUDIBLE],
a pretty fun episode.
MARK MANDEL: It's cute, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And then I'm going to be
doing another one soon,
but right after that,
I'm going to China.
I'm going to Shanghai to
speak at GopherCon China
and also going to be running
some workshops there, still
not completely planned.
But if you are in the
region around Shanghai,
definitely check
it out because I'll
be trying to do some Go
and Kubernetes workshops.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm heading
off to Vancouver.
I'll be there for the
week, I'll basically
be working out in
Vancouver for a bit.
But while I'm there I'll be
doing a Polyglot Vancouver
talk, I'll be talking
about gRPC and Kubernetes.
I will say, if
anyone's in Vancouver
and there's stuff that you
think I should check out, or do,
or tech stuff, or anything
along those lines,
or presentations you might
want made, drop me a line.
DMs are open on Twitter.
Outside of that I will be at
the East Coast Games Conference
talking about game
servers and Kubernetes.
And then shortly after
that, I will be at Vector.
That will be from the
18th of April onwards.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
If you want things
to do in Vancouver,
I have some very
good recommendations
for restaurants.
So good.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, Vancouver
food is excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well, I
think it's been a while
since we have not done this.
But I'm going to try to
reverse the roles this time.
So you're going to say, where,
and I'm going to say, how.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So what's the website?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: GCPodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: The email address?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
hello@gcpodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: Twitter?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: @GCPPodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Reddit?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: /r/gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Google+?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: +GCPPodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Slack?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, wow.
Yeah, that one's not
going to make it.
MARK MANDEL: #podcast--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: #podcast in the
Google Cloud Platform Community
that you can access
through bit.ly/--
MARK MANDEL: --gcp/slack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Exactly what I said.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So there you go.
If you have any
proposals, questions,
we're still looking for
more questions on the week.
We did last episode with that
question of the week that
was recording from someone.
If you send us a recording
with your question,
we will definitely use it.
It is always fun to
hear our listeners.
So send those our way.
And as always, thank
you, Mark, for yet
another amazing episode.
MARK MANDEL: And thank you,
Francesc, for joining me
for yet another episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And thank
you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]